Me and my little sister
going to check my nan
in Birmingham,
that's what we used
to call holidays back then.
What, and you didn't go
to the beach there?
The beach
in Birmingham, blood?
-Yeah, ain't there one?
-Are you stupid?
You're so… Do you know what?
I refuse to believe
that you're fucking serious
right now.
Where I've been…
people ain't really
that nice to you.
When they are…
you kinda always got
your guard up wondering why.
Remember them lavish meals
you used to cook up in here,
Miss Hill?
Used to come here
hoping you'd cook.
If I was lucky enough, boy,
come here and got
that ackee and saltfish
with the dumplings and that.
Yeah.
Don't forget them
times there.
That right there's
my little girl.
When her daddy comes home,
that little girl…
used to be standing
in front of her hero.
Not a fucking con
in prison stink.
Here comes the plane.
Go on, here comes the plane.
-How many kids have you got?
-Who said I have kids?
Look at it.
It's all moving and that.
What are you
gonna do with it?
I'm gonna cook it.
What are you gonna make?
I'm gonna make lobster.
It's a crab.
Do you believe in unicorns?
No.
Do you believe in aliens?
Yeah.
OK, at least
that's something.
These seagulls are bougie.
-They want the fish.
-Can you stop it, please?
Jas, I always knew
you were scared of birds.
Nothing like that.
I'm not scared of them.
I just don't like them, bro.
It's not funny, fam.
I ain't never seen
you with a bird, as it goes.
And this is my favourite.
The Tiger Who Came to Tea.
What's that about?
A tiger who came to tea.
Makes sense.
"We better open
the door and see."
"Sophie opened the door
and there was a big,
furry, stripy tiger.
And the tiger said…"
You scared me.
If you could have
anything, yeah…
What would it be?
-Anything?
-Do anything, have anything.
What would it be?
You know what?
To go watch Arsenal play.
'Cause they're the best
fucking team
in the whole Premier League.
-To come watch Arsenal?
-Yeah.
A'ight, it's done.
No.
Yeah.
You lost someone,
didn't you?
How are you feeling
about that?
It's like…
all this noise
is in my head.
It just don't ever go away.
What, you ain't got no
woman waiting for you?
Woman waiting for me?
No, man.
I'm not into all that, man.
Not into women, nah?
Nah, I'm into women,
but it's the relationships.
Yeah, don't worry,
when we get back,
me and you gonna find
some proper tings.
-Yeah.
-Trust me.
Yeah.